mark milly general
can he's amazing oh yeah i had the phone
call with china oh yeah i think that i
warned them i think that was the milly
thing it's a different topic but
the point i'm bringing up with this is
that we're at a point where aoc can
accept basically a 35 000 bribe
okay and mark millie can call the
chinese military and say
you know we're in a conflict that's had
been escalating and you've been engaging
in militaristic actions that we've been
telling you to stop doing
we won't attack you don't worry about it
so they're pressing on taiwan we send in
a strike group they they they start
loading up these missiles so we we
diversify our our air force around the
pacific islands and then millie's like
just don't worry we're not gonna attack
you
that that seems like something you
shouldn't tell your enemy when they're
when they're doing things in violation
of international law particularly thinks
they're not the enemy yeah i saw a
couple years ago where he was saying
they're very powerful they're getting
stronger but that doesn't mean there are
so the point is we can watch fauci lie
to congress and rand paul can have the
evidence
in a document that says the nih funded
gain of function research
nothing will happen lies
james clapper lied to congress that's
right those hillary clinton emails were
so insane the sydney blumenthal stuff in
libya so insane with with osprey global
scientists he died
i mean it was so so corrupt but i mean
the federal reserve it's so obvious but
what it's so obvious if you look at it
but if you don't look at it it's not
obvious and people they don't they look
past it when they see it they don't
understand it so they don't even see it
i don't know what's going on i got to be
honest i don't think we lived in a
republic since 1913. no we definitely
have not these people you know they're
getting bribed like i mean it's not a
legitimate republic there are people
there representing but they're they're
getting remember when j when lindsay
lindsey graham i think it was goes out
he's complaining about the election and
stuff then he goes out and he fist bumps
kamala harris yeah that's too hard it's
all nothing well taxi rich means
confiscate private property all the
communists believe they're gonna be the
commissars
they're all just stupid i got no problem
with
a right-wing politician walk up to a
left-wing politician and give him a fist
bump i got a problem with them
grandstanding on tv pretending like
they're morally opposed and then behind
closed doors be like i got your back i
have a problem with people claiming to
be
fighting for something and they don't
actually fight for it you know what one
of the problems is right now
mark milly
uh should be court-martialed yes hands
down al vindman of all people
i think he tweeted this out i don't know
where he posted i think it was a tweet
where he said
that if this is true mark miller usurped
civilian authority and by breaking the
chain of command
the new york times reported on this on
january 8th with an update on the 13th
that nancy pelosi
what well look there's a few pieces of
data missing
maybe trump told millie we're not going
to attack china maybe he told him that
but that's not what happened but maybe
he knew that but the issue is the
reporting is that it was a secret call
outside of chain of command and that
mark millie convened a secret meeting at
the pentagon instructing senior officers
to effect essentially defy legal legal
orders from donald trump
yes after a call from nancy pelosi now
what happened was the new york times
reported on january can we define
something very quickly
look i am not a mark millie fan i am a
donald trump supporter i hate nancy
pelosi i'm on the gum on the right side
but i have questions
my first question is is what is the
actual exact nuclear launch protocol
what does that have to do with this
because does the president just say
launch the nukes and then some guy in a
silo turns the key
or does it have to go from the president
to the joint chief
down the chain of command
what does it have to do with because as
far as i read the text specifically
milly said
if we're talking about a nuclear strike
it i have to be part of it or something
like that right which reinforced the
chain of command so what or what he
thought was the chain of command
what is the actual chain of command if
trump says launch the nukes where
what is the actual literal next step
does he give the order to the joint
chief
then then and then the guy that turns
the key has to take the order from the
joint chiefs or does he have to take it
from the president
this is this is a very important crucial
so let's
break this stuff down for you the hill
reported the forthcoming book says
millie conducted secret meetings at the
pentagon after january secret from whom
to ensure former president trump could
not launch a military attack secret from
the public secret from trump from trump
to ensure that trump could not launch a
military attack so suppose so specific
look i'm a trump guy i'm not a millie
guy i just want to have the facts so we
can argue the right things
and so he specifically said if donald
trump says attack
you come to me
look me in the eyes right now and swear
an oath you will come to me
with this
but
it gives but but it's shorter
to an officer and then he says no you
come to me instead
i i'm not in the military i have no idea
how this works
is an enlisted guy supposed to take an
order directly from the president or
does an enlisted guy have to take an
order from this commanding officer
before you jumped in okay the new york
times reported that when pelosi
contacted mark milley saying she was
concerned about donald trump launching a
military strike
that it seems mark millie offered no uh
consideration to this request
and the department of defense several
department of defense officials were
angered by this saying that if they
actually did plan on circumventing the
chain of command it would be a military
coup
vindman said if this report is correct
he that millie usurped civilian
authority breaking the chain of command
i am not saying it is my opinion this
happened i'm saying new york times
reported dod officials said if they
sought to break the chain of command it
would be a military coup
right if they thought to break the chain
of command but we haven't defined what
the chain of command is yeah yeah said
it was but vinman said that the
president can give an enlisted guy an
order that all that all of the
commanding officers disagree with and
then unless the guy has to do it i don't
jack i i think your questions are
completely irrelevant i think that
you're supposed to only answer to your
uh uh immediate officer your immediate
superior and then if another greater
spirit comes over and tells you
something you're like sorry
none of this is relevant to my people
that's what um
none of this is irrelevant relevant to
my point my point was that
according to the new york times when
they initially reported this they said
pelosi tried to make it happen
it didn't happen
and so i report that as
pelosi attempts military coup against
trump
and i said i'm not going to mince words
if the new york times reporting
department of defense officials said
what nancy pelosi attempted to get them
to do would have been a military coup
that's what i'm going to say happened
a lot of people left were angry by it no
that didn't happen she was just trying
to stop a crazy man from starting a a
war and i'm like
i don't care the new york times reported
this and i'm not going to give my
opinion i'm going to state what the new
york times reported vindeman says that
this report uh and you'll have to trust
vinman i'm just making the point
that
you have many people coming out right
now even people on the left saying this
broke the chain of command
he gave he gave information to an
adversary
without conferring with the president
that seems like a big problem to me
treason no we're not declared enemies of
china we actually have you know a ton of
agreements with them we're not at war
although we literally are at war we're
not well they're at war they're at war
with us we're with them we are well
they're they're at war with us they're
engaging they're waging war on us and
and
the point is we we didn't declare war
against them so it's just uh
an off the books conflict i guess you
can call it but they've been attacking
our critical infrastructure for a long
long time so anyway the point is
millie
according to the reports held a secret
had a secret phone call with chinese
military
telling them outright
all of our posturing
all of our our our ships going through
china we're not gonna attack you that's
actually makes me think that we have way
better ties with the chinese government
than it seems that we're really safe and
there's not going to be any physical
conflict
china recently had a strike group go
into the alaskan economic zone and
look when china says we will or right up
next to the economics
when china says we will
take taiwan
when china is actively sinking fishing
boats in the south china sea claiming
control over it when they're illegally
building military bases on the atolls
and the u.s can only saber rattle and
then the best we have is saber rattling
mark millie in october before the
election even happened calls them and
says don't worry we're not gonna attack
you
and if we are going to i will give you
advanced warning is this not and again
i'm not a milli fan i'm a trump
supporter i believe china is waging war
on us etc i just wanted to know the
facts okay
if we're conducting a military exercise
do we not notify our adversaries in
advance that we're conducting a military
exercise wait wait wait are you asking
that if we're going to fire a missile on
our enemy to declare war we would warn
them first and exercise but that's not
what we're talking about he said
so you need to understand what's been
going on all last year
china has been actively pushing on the
pacific in many ways that are considered
illegal sinking fishing boats for
instance has been a huge red flag for
the u.s and its and their allies so the
u.s deploys destroyers into the south
china sea challenging china's claims
over the territory china's trying to put
enough pressure on the u.s to get us to
back down so they can eventually declare
sovereignty over the area
one of the things stopping them was that
china was scared if they kept pressing
the u.s would attack
so mark millie this is reported in in
the full report from the washington post
in the book
they specifically state
because china was concerned that the u.s
would be prepared to attack them mark
milley called them in october of 2020 to
warn them not to worry we will not
attack you everything is fine and in the
event we will launch an attack i will
call you and warn you first
that was him pledging to an adversary in
the event war were to break out he would
side with them he would give them
warning of our military plans yes and by
stating that we will not attack you he
completely undermined everything the u.s
had been doing in the pacific to stop
china's encroachment in the pacific when
china was scared we were we're going to
attack that i'm not saying war is good
no it's bad but if china was like hey
the u.s might attack us you think that's
a deterrent right so he undermined that
completely
going outside of the chain of command to
do so right secretly secretly contacting
the chinese military to inform them and
is and he said as you mentioned ian in
the past when he said that china is not
our enemy
china's been conducting cyber warfare
against us for
no forever they're very clearly waging
war on us there's no question about it
i'll tell you by my number
my number one source and look again i'm
just trying to figure out what the facts
are right here and i'm not an expert
look i know a lot of stuff about a lot
of things but i do not i'm not an expert
on chinese incursions into the south
china sea okay i can admit that uh the
the source of my skepticism
is the fact that this was reported in a
bob woodward book okay and just if it
really confirmed it fine
but if it came out last year and it was
about trump it was about bob woodward
everyone on our side or my side at least
would be like that bob woodward is an
idiot and a liar that's that that's yes
but he confirmed it fair enough yeah he
said it was it was it was he said it was
acceptable and routine and we regularly
so
maybe maybe it is acceptable and routine
then why so so the issue i suppose then
is when you've done something that's so
shocking once again you see everyone on
the right saying this is shocking if
true that even people on the left are
coming out like that's why i cited
vendeman specifically yeah i'm not
trying to claim that he's an expert in
authority on this i'm saying he's the
guy who tried to get trump impeached or
who did get trump impeached now coming
out and being like this broke the chain
of command but there aren't there are
also other incidences where like we've
attacked people and i think i think this
is pretty common we're like we're going
to launch a missile on this on this base
like with trump in syria you should move
you should move some people out of there
we don't want to kill a bunch of people
we just want to blow up a bunch of
equipment we're launching this missile
missile's coming
i mean notifying our adversaries in
advance of a military attack is not
unprecedented not in the age of limited
war i think the issue is that he went
around donald trump okay
that's fine again let me let me read
something for you i can feel the
comments this is new york times
new york times january 8 with an update
on january 13th they mentioned speaker
pelosi of california took the
unprecedented step of asking the
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
about available precautions to prevent
trump from initiating military action
abroad or using his sole authority to
launch nuclear weapons in the last days
of his term so apparently has sole
authority to launch nuclear weapons i
guess general milley has appears to have
made no commitments that's what they
said in january we now know that he did
in fact had a secret meeting at the
pentagon where he he according to the
book and again you know got to believe
woodward
he asked these officers to effectively
swear an oath to him that if trump gave
him an order they'd go to him with it
first
okay that's that's the question i want
to know
that's the question i want to know so
let me read does the president can the
president yes i understand the question
let me read
millie made no commitments mrs pelosi's
request which she announced in the
democratic caucus is an effort to
prevent an unhinged president from using
the nuclear codes was wrapped in the
politics of seeking a second impeachment
of trump colonel david butler spokesman
for general milley confirmed the phone
call with the speaker had taken place
but described it as informational he
answered her questions regarding the
process of nuclear command authority but
some defense department officials
clearly resented being asked to act
outside of the legal authority of the
25th amendment and saw it as more
evidence of a broken political system
they said that some political leaders
were trying to get the pentagon to do
the work of congress and cabinet
secretaries who have legal options to
remove a president mr trump they noted
is still the commander-in-chief unless
he is removed the military is bound to
follow his lawful orders while military
officials can refuse to carry out orders
they view as illegal or slow the process
by sending those orders for careful
legal review they cannot remove the
president from the chain of command that
would amount to a military coup the
official said
okay that being said if vindman is
correct in saying that this broke chain
of command if there was there was
another retire retired colonel on fox
news who said outright this was an
illegal action by milly if true he
should be brought into congress put
under oath and testifies to what
happened
we have people left right military
coming out and saying this was a
subversive action against the united
states treason we're not at war with
china
formally in which case i don't think it
counts as treason uh court martialable
i'm not in the military i wouldn't know
if it goes against the um
the the military code or anything like
that but i certainly think that mark
milley has
acted
beyond reproach the secret meeting at
the pentagon now this one's not
confirmed what is confirmed is that
miley has admitted to this this phone
call with china on more than one
occasion on in october and in january
8th
the claim from the left in the
mainstream media is that he was just
trying to stop an unhinged president who
he had seen who he believed was in
mental decline following an insurrection
attempt except he made the first call in
october according to the reporting
well before an election took place so
imagine donald trump who's been very
very bullish on you know going up
against china
imagine he won the election he had
already been undermined by the joint the
chairman of the joint chiefs who went
around who went behind his back to
contact china
and that's admitted now it's routine you
know i talk to the militaries of all
these other countries all the time
but there's a lot of people in the
military said not true okay so here's
why i see it fine maybe it's not uh
treason maybe it's not court-martial how
about we the people who are requesting
an investigation and an inquiry into
this one get it and we we get to the
bottom of it and then we determine
whether or not he brought senior
officers into the pentagon to tell them
that if trump gives you an order you
bring it to me
we still in that article didn't get a
clear delineation of what the nuclear
command structure is well i i suppose
they pointed out its sole authority of
the president but what is the chain of
command does the president go to the key
turner directly or does it have to go
down the line that's important
distinction you know look well so let's
put this we spent so much time parsing
text
when it came to trump and watching the
left take things that trump said that
were specifically accurate but then
expanding it into being generally
inaccurate and i just don't want us to
do that
like i just want us to be specific and
to look right and justified in our
critiques so the ultimate question is
can donald trump
get on the phone to they don't use norad
anymore i guess but can you get on the
phone to a commander to military base
with nuclear capabilities and say
launch the nukes yeah i believe the
answer is yes i believe the answer is no
you don't think true my instinct is i
don't i have no other basis trump is the
one with the nuclear football who else
would be able to do it yeah i don't know
seems to me that uh in something that
could end the world that we would want
it to go down the chain of command from
one officer to the command i think the
democrats tried to make that happen
actually they tried to take biden's sole
authority for the nuclear launch codes
away and give it to somebody give it to
more than just him
i think it's him now i understand the
question is down the chain of command
i i would be surprised if trump could
not call
you know strategic defense you know a
commander captain a major a general or
whatever who has the ability to turn the
key and say this is president donald
trump calling on the red phone he could
you know i'm sure he had to call a
general i suppose but he doesn't call
millie right yeah so if millie as the
chairman of the joint chiefs now here's
the important part as chairman of the
joint chiefs he's not active in the
military he's an advisor he's a so it's
it's colo it's it's semantic but my
understanding based on the reporting is
that as the chairman of the joint chiefs
he acts as the senior military adviser
to the president and doesn't make the
decisions himself which means trump
would not go to him to execute the
decisions gotcha he would go to the
senior officers the generals and say
do it for him to come out and be like no
you come to me instead
i don't know man uh
calling china at a time when we're
facing thucydides trap sounds to me like
providing aid to the enemy thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time